okay I feel like everybody has a Woody
Allen story so what was the story for
you
I met Woody Allen four bullets over
Broadway and shadows in fog like 20
years ago and you know I've done tons of
independent movies in the 90s and I get
asked to be on juries at different
festivals and I met the the program
directors at the Cracow Film Festival
and they had been asking me for years to
come and I went and I was on the jury
with Juliette Taylor and the casting
director casting director for Woody
Allen and they have a very close
relationship and she you know feels out
what actors are right for his movies and
she is very selective in what she shows
him because he doesn't really like to
meet actors so I got back from Krakow
and Juliette got to know me a little
more and at this time in my life and we
all lost our bags on Monday and I got
called on Wednesday to meet woody on
Thursday at noon and on Friday I got
cast the meeting was three and a half
minutes and so you get twenty pages well
not no not everyone goes twenty pages
mi and Joaquin got the entire script and
I got twenty pages and on the page it's
really funny you know like I was
shopping at the liquor store thought I'd
come in and got a bottle for me and my
husband and and I show up on set and
it's not that tone at all I mean it's
much darker and so that was that was an
amazing to have no conversation but to
come with with everything you know and
then to be shown that it's a whole other
body of water and so I was kept in the
dark and it was uh it was a great
working experience it was really
creative is there any rehearsal at all
or would that knock out that quality if
you that's right there's no there's no
rehearsal which is great you know the
Christopher Guest movies there's no
rehearsal and no talking with what
you're doing and with the other actors
either it's not like oh I have something
funny let's work this out and be funny
with it you're really creating something
live on camera and he that's how woody
works too but he'll say he'll come in
and what what are we doing today
oh wait wait go over to you and say what
I wrote isn't very good if you add
something anything you'd like to say and
add to the scene to make it better than
what I wrote and you can do that and and
it's just this kind of effortless like
loose thing we're gonna want to do this
in one take you know it's like that's
that's the vibe that's the vibe it is
very jazz how many nights you get one
seriously yeah you get one take and so
um he comes over and he says that was
you know good or sometimes it's not you
know and you're like cuz that was good
there's the right temperature but we
have to go again for sound and then
you're like okay so you have to really
take it take the bull by the horns and
really and really jump in were you
wanting directorial notes from him I
knew really not like that um I when I
went to a drama school in SUNY Purchase
actors didn't want to rehearse with me
because I'd be like you're killing it
you're gonna kill the scene if you keep
you know if you rehearse it so I'd like
to I like paying attention to the other
actor in front of me and just being in
the moment being loose and yeah I don't
I don't like
yeah I'm usually left alone but that's
just the way independent movies are -
like you've done your work so there's
not a lot of talking you know but he
would come in and just say just a little
more that was good but no irony on this
line just a little bit and you know he's
so subtle one thing I didn't know it
just as I was researching a little bit
more about Woody's films is that
apparently a good number of them as do a
lot of films require additional
photography after the principal shoot
did you guys have to go back and do
anything yes the first day I worked I
did 20 takes of the bar scene
and I heard that a lot of the time the
first day is is is reshot the bar scene
where you're presenting your Midori
yeah and that was exciting to have them
really you know work with me I was it
was terrifying I was screaming and
laughing and forgetting my lines so what
happened with that scene it was cool
they just you know I played it a bunch
of different ways and if there was
something that I we didn't have to
reshoot it but they but he got whatever
he needed to get out of me he got out of
me in the in his direction but there was
a few scenes that they that day that
they did reshoot and of course there's a
you know the fear that you're going to
be cut entirely because of that movie
that he did where he recast yeah
so that can happen and that's he can he
can do that it's his story you know as
an actor in his movie you're very much
in his story like immediately at the
camera test I'm like hi what's your name
but really he would it's like he wanted
me to be Rita and Suzy Benziger the
wardrobe designer told me that you know
make sure you just go in there and you
are the character and and then the same
in you know we've we block just a little
bit rehearse just a little bit so yeah
we do rehearse but is
like talked about its and it's a lot of
this like we have five minutes to do
this you know it's very jazz it has a
really improvisational vibe are you sad
that it didn't happen that you didn't
get to work with him 20 years ago or are
you happy that it happened now oh I'm so
happy that it happened now why because
I've experienced so much and you know
his movies to me were about adults
feeling feelings and there and being
able to having an intelligence about
them and an awareness that is like
classic it's like check off for
Strindberg or like it's very deep and I
don't feel like I could have embodied
that at a younger age
well you did a great job in this Parker
I'm really glad you finally got to work
with Woody Allen me too thank you all
for hanging around with us